you pointed to the 2000s
as like your kind of like heavy
celebrity time
to me that that seemed kind of odd
because for me it would be like well of
course the 80s
and uh yeah the 80s well okay so
in the course of skating skating got
popular in the 80s for sure
but it was still very much considered a
novelty
and so obviously we as skaters who grew
up there
thought it was everything but like it
was never on the news
you know what i mean it was never right
it was never
in mainstream it was rarely in
commercials and stuff like that what it
was and and i think that this this would
probably be pretty accurate
is that uh nobody knew about it at all
and then 1985 back to the future came
out
and every kid in the world got a
skateboard for christmas that year
yep in 1985 and like
98 of those kids found out very quickly
how difficult skateboarding is you know
it's like wait a second this
isn't fun i like this is hard and like i
fell down and i didn't like that that
hurts
you know and so it's a very small
percentage of
the kids who get a skateboard that
actually go on to become in any way
proficient
and that whole process serves to
totally weed out any kids that are
like just half-assed you know you you
have really isolated with skateboarding
like the most driven persistent like
like willing to sacrifice like
you know like go to any lengths it's a
pretty special person who is a
skateboarder
and like at this time they were talking
about it wasn't cool
you know yeah so you choose to skate and
then it's hard
and also everyone's telling you to not
do it or telling you can't do it right
parents are telling you not i mean it
was just you had to really persevere
even just to do it for fun at all not to
be serious about it
but fast forward to so i think you're
right like back to the future was
definitely a catalyst for people to
start skating
the next sort of wave of that was i
believe our video game series
because it there are a bunch of pros
these days that started
skating because they played it on a
video game yeah
and yeah that's odd to me but i believe
it cuz
that's not your era so um but i mean i'm
talking about like some of the best
writers in the world
a guy like shane o'neill he played our
video game series and thought
all that stuff's possible yeah and then
and then he made that he started doing
it
and this is the guy who wins the battle
at the barracks
like routinely i love tony hawk
and he's raising money to build
skateparks by selling
a limited number of these hand-signed
legendary photos and there's a link in
the bio to get one
so help tony hawk build skate parks
okay buy a hand signed
freaking print yeah dude
yeah dude